joining us now with reaction chicago
police union president
john uh canazzara is with us
uh john thank you for being here all
right i can show the pictures
and i'll show the still pictures you can
see clearly
that that adam toledo has a gun
in his right hand just in a fraction
it's less than a second the police
officer has to decide
is as he's turning it seemed like he
flipped the gun is that what you see
that's absolutely what happened eight
tenths of a second
that's it now you can see the gun in the
picture
and right behind that barrier that wall
there
that's where the gun was found so it was
seemed to be flicked
flipped or dropped by adam toledo
how does the officer possibly know
whether when he's
there seeing the gun turning
and to put his hands up that he flipped
it he didn't know that did he
no he had no idea that it had left his
hand by the time it popped back out from
behind that fence
and again i've said it time and time
again our officers not only in chicago
in illinois or even in this country are
under no obligation
to be fired upon or struck by gunfire
before defending their own life
we're not and it should never be i don't
know if that's that long game here
or what they attend the policies to be
that we have to you know
subject ourselves to gunfire before we
take action but it's absolutely
ridiculous
okay so let's talk a little bit more
about the need for body cams because i
think
footage you know helps us tell the whole
story here
so in this case if this police officer
didn't have his body cam
on would it be a very different future
for him at this point
well i think it'd be a lot murkier i i
think the fact that the weapon was
recovered right there you'd still have
the video
from the high school that shows the long
shot down the alley
and it clearly shows the subject
discarding something behind the fence
but you know there was a disgusting
press conference yesterday and before we
even get to there
you talked about the the victims in
chicago uh
less than one mile away from where that
incident occurred last night a 17 year
old girl
was struck by a bullet and ended up
dying at the hospital traveling in a car
at 7 pm in broad daylight right down the
street from where that happened
subjected to the same silly non-reckless
actions
that those two took that night by
shooting at a vehicle this is a common
occurrence there
but the mayor in her press conference
never even once mentioned the word gangs
not once but talked about the police
department and
systemic racism and everything else
under the sun but
not never anything about the gangs i'm
trying to understand and wrap my arms
around and i'll plead guilty
to when my kids were younger uh being a
helicopter parent
i i'm having a hard time coming to grips
with
this young man 13 years old on a monday
night
out with a 21 year old convict with a
gun violation
and being out at 2 30 in the morning
nothing good
my father used to say nothing good
happens after midnight
nothing good is ever going to happen to
a 13 year old
at that time in the morning out with
somebody with that track record
i agree and you know i i cautioned you
know going too hard after the mothers
you know i was a school resource officer
for four years
i started talking to your mother no no
no no i'm just saying it
was sad well i agree but there's been a
lot of conversation
about the mother and him not being home
yet again and not reported missing
a second time but my point was that
i've seen this many many times where
parents are just at wit's ends
with kids who are being led astray and
they don't know what to do with them
especially at that age where they're so
impressionable you know
this does fall at cps's doorstep if the
teachers were
in school teaching and he was in school
learning
whether he was in bed waiting for the
next day at some point a teacher or a
counselor
may have been able to get at least his
attention and steer him in a different
direction
rather than the 21 year old and the
latin king gang
yeah all right john kat and zara thank
you so much for being with us we
appreciate it
now this week